tous les jours je me suis plainte à mes
supérieurs hiérarchiques jamais jamais
ils n'ont pu faire arrêter cette chose
là
Marinette vous avez 40 ans et demi
bientôt 41 vous êtes mère de 6 enfants
vous êtes préposés à la poste et donc
vous vous trouvez en arrêt maladie parce
que vous avez fait une dépression
nerveuse liée à votre travail
oui effectivement
j'ai été victime de harcèlement sexuel
sur le lieu de mon travail par d'autres
mes collègues
l'année dernière au mois de mai
c'est-à-dire que tout était déclenché à
l'annonce de du projet de loi de la loi
sur le harcèlement sexuel
en mai 92 avril c'était à peu près ils
ont commencé à me chahuter assez assez
durement au moment où la loi est passée
avant quand on en a parlé ils vont faire
une loi sur le harcèlement sexuel est-ce
que si je te fais ça c'est du
harcèlement sexuel alors c'est simple on
me passer les cernes pincer les fesses
j'ai même eu un collègue qui s'est
permis de me prendre à plusieurs
reprises par les épaules de me serrer
très fort et puis de de mettre des coups
de rats sur moi dans la hanche des
choses comme ça
et
lorsque ce garçon un matin un vendredi
matin on prend ma prise de service à
6h20 c'est emparé d'un rouleau un
rouleau que c'est qui contient une
affiche rouler qui fait environ 20
mètres de long sur 8 cm de diamètre
c'est permis alors que j'étais penché
sur un sur un roulante ce qu'on appelle
chez nous pour trier des paquets me l'a
mis entre les fesses
bien sûr
j'ai immédiatement réagi
je l'ai giflais et je me suis mise en
colère il n'y avait rien eu avant
auparavant qui pouvait quelquefois vous
savez des des mauvaises blagues un petit
peu ce qui me faisait rire à ce
moment-là pas toujours enfin je les
remettais à leur place
mais je suis quelqu'un qui est quand
même assez très fort et jusqu'ici
j'avais très très bien géré cette
situation c'est cette loi qui les a
excités je sais je sais pas je sais pas
ce que ça a pu déclencher en eux
c'est curieux ça a été une mobilisation
générale de tous ces hommes de voir
jusqu'où il pouvait aller je sais pas je
sais pas ce qu'ils ont voulu se prouver
ce ne sont que des hommes je travaille
au paquet moi particulièrement au paquet
la brigade paquet dans laquelle je suis
je ne travaille qu'avec des sommes ils
sont combien vous êtes combien au total
on est une douzaine et vous êtes la
seule femme voilà aucun homme nous a
protégé
absolument pas au contraire il y en a
qui se sont carrément mis contre moi
alors ensuite dans les jours qui ont
suivi il y en a un qui était un peu plus
que les autres et alors celui-là il m'a
empoisonné la vie pendant un mois
absolument tous les jours sans exception
il m'a harcelé
verbalement en employeur des mots en me
chantant des chansons horribles il me il
me chantait Marinette suce-moi la
quéquette ça faisait rire toute la
cantonade sauf moi bien sûr et tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours tous
les jours tous les jours je me suis
plainte à mes supérieure hiérarchiques
jamais jamais ils n'ont pu faire arrêter
cette chose là ils n'ont plus ils n'ont
pas voulu
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas voulu moi
j'accuse tous mes supérieurs
hiérarchiques d'avoir contribué à en
venir à m'avoir rendu malade
en laissant faire en utilisant pas
l'autorité et les moyens qu'ils peuvent
avoir pour faire arrêter ce genre de
choses je suis désolé malgré la volonté
qu'on peut avoir il arrive un jour on ne
peut plus on ne peut plus tenir moi je
suis quelqu'un qui qui dormait plus je
ne mangeais plus j'ai perdu 12 kilos
pendant ce mois
tellement j'étais perturbée et puis
j'avais je me demandais je me demandais
si on me croyait parce que on ne faisait
rien disait oui je vais intervenir mais
c'était tous les jours c'est à dire que
tout ce temps de harcèlement sexuel ça a
duré combien un mois un mois c'est
presque jour pour jour parce que la
première fois ça a été le 22 vraiment où
il y a eu des gestes déplacés vers moi
violents avec ce rouleau c'était le 22
mai et j'ai cessé mon travail le 22 juin
vous avez complètement craqué ah oui de
toute façon je ne pouvais plus assumer
mon travail normalement je travaillais
mal j'aurais même risqué de commettre
des erreurs je travaillais dans des
conditions épouvantables je pleurais
toute la journée c'était normal je l'ai
travaillé j'allais chez mes clients avec
des lunettes noires pour dissimuler un
petit peu le visage complètement ravagé
que j'avais
on peut pas jouer longtemps avec sa
santé de toute façon vous en avez parlé
vous à votre mari dans votre entourage
immédiatement mon mari immédiatement
justement dans les cas de harcèlement
sexuel je sais parce que j'ai eu des
femmes qui vont nous parler il y a des
femmes qui sont harcelées sexuellement
même chez nous à la poste et elle garde
ça pour elle il y a des femmes qui sont
harcelées qui n'en ont jamais parlé leur
mari moi je pense que dans ce genre de
situation parce que ça rend malade ça
même en se confiant ça rend malade parce
que on se pose des tas de questions on
se demande on se demande si quelque part
on n'est pas fautif puisqu'on nous
traite comme tel moi pendant jusqu'en
jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore je me demande
je pense que l'administration me prend
comme coupable et comme victime mais
vous quelle question vous êtes posées je
me suis demandé si quelque part
effectivement j'avais pas motivé cette
cette réaction de mes collègues je me
suis demandé si quelque part j'étais pas
effectivement coupable si c'était pas
moi qui était mal conduite et qui
qui était pleinement responsable en fait
de cette situation
j'avais un autre côté vu les pressions
qu'on faisait sur moi j'avais
l'impression qu'on me croyait pas et
votre mari lui vous a cru immédiatement
absolument
un appui fabuleux dans mon mari
d'ailleurs si je tiens le coup
aujourd'hui je pense que je peux le
remercier parce que il m'a vraiment
beaucoup aidé qu'est-ce qui vous a
conseillé de faire lui tout de suite lui
porter plainte c'était parce qu'il faut
dire que depuis
tout ces toutes ces histoires il y a eu
des tas de problèmes au sein du couple
il y a des problèmes sur le plan sexuel
il y a des problèmes
ça vous démolit quelque part ça vous dit
ça
et puis dans cette histoire là je n'ai
eu à faire parmi mes supérieurs
hiérarchiques des hommes encore
ce qui veut dire
que
notre mari ne pouvait plus vous
approcher pendant un certain temps
chaque voulait dire
maintenant c'est pas toujours évident ça
eu autant d'incidences vous dans votre
vie privée
oui je pense que d'ailleurs on ne peut
même pas les expliquer on peut pas les
décrire c'est des choses qui se vivent
il faut faire semblant quelquefois
il faut être femme il faut être mère il
faut être maîtresse il faut il faut
faire tout le faut assumer et c'est un
tout en fait ça vous détruit partout
Marinette c'est un peu comme si vous en
parliez de un peu comme un viol enfin
quelque chose qui ressemble à ça je l'ai
ressenti comme ça moi
je pourrais vous dire je me suis plus
centrée par sentie pareille tout le
monde sait que les femmes sont coquettes
je fais partie de celle là j'ai perdu ma
coquetterie j'ai changé mon physique
j'avais des cheveux très très courts
jusque l'année dernière depuis je me
suis laissé pousser les cheveux j'ai
plus envie d'avoir la même tête
en fait je vous entends bien Marinette
c'est qui se passe ça à votre travail ça
a été le déclencheur d'autre chose parce
que c'est pas le travail qui fait que
tout à coup vous avez autant de
problèmes chez vous pas du tout c'est
pas le travail qui me rend malade
d'ailleurs ça me rend malade de pas
travailler mais actuellement je ne peux
pas travailler on a vraiment essayé de
m'embêter quand je dis m'embêter je suis
modeste on a un inspecteur ce fameux
inspecteur qui qui comprenait pas ma
réaction m'a menacé en me disant qu'il
me ferait virer il m'avait assez au
téléphone ça qui me faisait virer que la
plaisanterie avait ségurer qu'il fallait
que je retourne au boulot que
il allait me faire contrôler
médicalement
ça c'est d'ailleurs pas fait attendre
parce que le lendemain sur le lendemain
j'avais une convocation pour me rendre
chez sa première médecin
pour voir si on arrêt de travail était
justifié je me suis donc rendue à ce
premier contrôle médical et ce médecin
je lui ai expliqué ce qui m'a réveillé
il a donc confirmé mon arrêt de travail
et ce monsieur m'a dit mais madame
d'ailleurs il m'a rendu service des
inspecteur parce que ce médecin m'a dit
mais madame ce qui vous arrive là c'est
très grave il ne faut pas laisser ça là
il faut déposer une plainte il faut
saisir le procureur de la République et
ce médecin donc téléphoné à la
préfecture et je suis reparti de son
bureau avec toutes les adresses et toute
la manière de faire sinon effectivement
je sais pas si j'aurais été jusqu'à
porter plainte parce que c'est quand
même une décision à prendre qui est
grave faut pas oublier que le
harcèlement sexuel est passible de peine
de prison
et que dans les deux harceleurs il y a
un homme qui est marié qui a des enfants
si grande la prison les parents lui bon
je sais pas vous y avez pensé à ça je
pense à me perturber énormément il a
trois enfants lui aussi il a une femme
qui est-ce qui va être puni plus
là-dedans c'est pas lui c'est sa famille
qu'est-ce que vous voulez oui quelle
heure est-il la solution pour vous la
solution est que quand je suis allée me
plaindre j'avais demandé un changement
de brigade c'est à dire que je n'aurais
pu travailler avec ces personnes là je
pense que on aurait dû me l'accepter
c'est inspecteur n'a pas voulu il n'a
pas voulu ah non il me l'a refusé
catégoriquement
à la limite non ce qui cherche je pense
que cet homme-là cherchait peut-être à
ce que j'en vienne à démissionner et
puis il a essayé de faire pression sur
moi pour pas que j'aille jusqu'à la
plainte mais ça ne lui a pas suffi ce
contrôle médical je crois que c'est à
peine un mois après j'avais un nouveau
contrôle médical
le médecin bien sûr a confirmé mon arrêt
je crois que c'est encore un mois plus
tard j'ai eu droit au contrôle
psychiatrique cette fois
je suis tombé sur un médecin qui m'a
confirme qui a confirmé mon arrêt de
travail comme étant justifié
et j'ai eu un deuxième examen
psychiatrique contrôle le psychiatrique
au mois de janvier
avec ce même psychiatre
et il faut dire que dans notre fête il y
avait les résultats de l'enquête
administrative
qui
avait reconnu mortellement sexuel ça a
été assez couché noir sur blanc
situation de harcèlement sexuel et puis
il y a le détail des sanctions qui l'ont
été qui ont été prises à l'encontre de
ces deux collègues oui lesquels alors ça
c'est c'est assez étonnant le la
personne qui a eu un geste déplacé
envers moi a eu de sévères observations
quant à celui qui m'a persécuté pendant
plus d'un mois qui m'a rendu malade qui
m'a foutu complètement l'air il a eu un
blâme
en fait c'est rien c'est-à-dire qu'ils
sont toujours au même poste absolument
aujourd'hui je retravaille
je suis obligé de retravailler avec eux
il n'a pas été envisagé que soit déplacé
on a beaucoup envisagé de me déplacer
moi vous oui je suis désolé je veux pas
perdre ma tournée c'est mon droit parce
que si on me déplace je vais perdre une
titularisation de tournée je me
retrouvais à rouler faire des
remplacements c'est l'enfer
le manque de respect qu'on a envers moi
je suis désolé moi je suis pas une bête
on n'a pas le droit de me traiter comme
ça
si je dis qu'on veut que je veux qu'on
me respecte on doit le faire on l'avait
toujours fait avant je vois pas pourquoi
d'un seul coup ça basculerait et puis
que faudrait que j'accepte ça c'est pas
normal ça qu'est-ce qui va se passer
parce que ça fait 10 mois presque que
vous êtes maintenant en congé maladie
ordinaire alors que normalement j'aurais
pu être en congé longue durée ce qu'on
appelle
alors l'inconvénient que j'ai en étant
en congé maladie c'est que si je n'ai
pas rembauché au bout des au bout d'un
an d'arrêt c'est-à-dire le 22 juin
je vais me retrouver certainement en
disponibilité
sans salaire
je suis déjà debitraitement depuis le
mois de septembre les mois passent et on
est en train d'essayer de me faire
partir de la Poste on est en train
d'essayer de me [__] au placard ou de
me faire démissionner je sais pas à moi
qu'on essaie de me démolir complètement
ça me perturbe énormément d'être là dans
l'anxiété de savoir si je pouvais
retravailler ou pas
le procès aura lieu quand c'est assez
long mais actuellement
l'enquête est en cours
et je pense que faut couper à peu près
deux ans Marinette en fait tout a été un
peu comme ça en étage j'ai eu plusieurs
souffrances
la première qui était d'être atteinte
dans votre dignité absolument
dans ma dignité de femmes de
et puis la souffrance de travail bien
sûr pas pouvoir nous priver de mon
travail
et après 11 années on est passé donc aux
années c'est ça au mois de au mois de
décembre que je suis à la poste le fait
de tout à coup ne pas être cru de vous
retrouver
bafouer d'une certaine manière
absolument moi j'ai rempli mon contrat
j'ai travaillé pour la poste je
contribue comme tous les autres petits
préposés à faire prospérer cette
entreprise c'est ce qu'on attend de nous
c'est ce que nos patrons attendent de
nous mais qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
récompense que tu nous arrive quelque
chose
rien
l'abandon totale
c'est comme si j'existais pas
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]